trying to find peace we're three days
ago there was none people are coming to
the Emmanuel Baptist Church to share
their grief and some even to forgive
the man arrested for the killings Dylann
roof blank-faced as he was led into his
bail hearing facing the court by video
link he's accused of murdering nine
people roof stared at the floor as
victims relatives told the court hearing
of their grief but also of their
determination to forgive you I think you
thought something precious away from I
would never talk to her ever again Alain
Delon giving a whole over again but I
think it for you and Harris neo-soul at
a local college the baseball team is
grieving with one of its players
Christopher singleton lost his mother in
the attack we are mourning right now but
I know we will get through it my mom was
a god-fearing woman she loved everybody
with all her heart you know till to the
other families I'm sorry about what
happened and all the reports suggest
that roof recently received a gun as a
present President Obama has blamed
congressional Republicans for blocking
tougher gun control laws no reform can
guarantee the elimination of violence
but we might still have some more
Americans with us we might have stopped
one shooter
some families might still be whole short
of any real change Charleston's example
of forgiveness could be one small ray of
hope